one of the criticisms of the red pill
movement is some people will say oh
they're too focused on money and it's
interesting I think when people think of
money many think of car fancy things
cars and your house for me as a kid who
didn't grow up with money to me money
meant Freedom money meant the ability to
pick up your family and move somewhere
else if you need to money meant if your
businesses was Lot was locked down in
New York during the pandemic some people
were able to move to Florida and start
up a new business others got buried
unfortunately so for me I feel that the
message is earn money so that you can be
self-sufficient so you are not dependent
on the system and you have that Mobility
but I'm curious for someone like you
because you talked about being an earner
you obviously have accumulated you know
a lot of wealth been very very
successful if one of your sons came to
you honestly and said Dad
you know what um I want to be a teacher
I want to be a preschool teacher or I
want to be a third grade teacher and I
want to be the soccer coach and that's
what makes me really happy would there
be any part of you that would be
concerned about that in terms of will he
be a sufficient earner or would be
worried about whether or not he could be
a high-value man just based on numerical
limitations salary wise does that come
to mind for someone who's achieved such
enormous Financial stability and success
like yourself yeah great question so one
the shadow I think the shadow is the
concern I'm more concerned about the
shadow than I am about what this kid's
going to decide to do with his life so
let me break these two things down so
six months ago five months ago I come
home and my oldest son comes in he says
Jennifer's like hey babe talk to Patrick
everybody today was Googling Patrick
David and they saw your stuff in
valuetainment came up and all this stuff
I'm like okay oh awesome hey Chico so
tell me about your day I don't want to
talk about it
you don't want to talk about it because
we have the same name so I don't talk
about it so you don't want to talk about
it no I don't want to talk about it that
and he's not disrespectful he just
doesn't want to talk about him he never
talks to me like that before
so it's bedtime he's going upstairs I
said I gotta go talk to Tico so I go
upstairs what happened today why were
you saying you didn't want to talk about
it so I just don't want to talk about it
that and he's covering his face with a
blanket he never does that this guy's
very uncomfortable comfortable with me
so I said can I ask you a question he
said yes I said are you worried because
we have the same name and you have to
live up to what your daddy's done is
that kind of your concern because
everyone's Googling my picture comes up
he says I am I say okay cool no problem
so that's a valid concern I said can we
can I give you some options to see what
you want to do he says yeah I said do
you want to change your name
let's change your name
I don't want to I love my name I said do
you love your name he says yeah so why
do you love your name because it's you
my first name and my grandpa's my middle
name Gabriel and I love my last name I
said so you don't want to change your
name I said no so your concern isn't the
fact that you don't want the pressure
having my name your concern is what you
think I want you to be me I do so you
think I want you to run an insurance
company one day and be Daddy yes so do
you want to be no so you don't have to
be I said Daddy what do you want to do
in your life he says daddy you know what
I want to do in life I said what do you
want to do tell me I already know why
won't you tell me I want to make movies
and I want to tell stories I said no
problem I said well what are the four
things we do in the bed David family he
says we lead we respect we improve we
love we don't bully we don't get bullied
and we pray for four things courage
wisdom tolerance understanding yes daddy
I said I don't care what industry you
choose to go in the only expectation I
have of you is to make sure you do those
four things if you go in any industry I
expect you to lead respect improve and
love in any situation you're in that's
the David MO
so he says so you really don't want me
to do what you do when I grew up I said
not at all buddy you go do whatever you
want to do I just want to see you be
your best the only thing is when you
make movies can I go watch movies for
free when your movies comes out he says
I think I'll give you and Mommy free
tickets and he's actually not going and
then we change the subject and he's now
dreaming once again look you and I get a
chance to set the tone and the
expectation with our kids are they going
to follow that yeah they're going to
live their own lives I only got eight
more years with this kid that's it he's
ten eight more years he's on his own he
gets to do what he wants to do without
my permission yeah so I have only eight
more years to impose my philosophies my
standards my expectations my method of
reasoning and he gets to choose to do
whatever he wants to do with that for
the next 72 years because he's most
likely going to live up to 90 years old
I can't do nothing from there on I can
only be a positive influence from the
back supporting him so it wouldn't
bother me if they chose to be any of
that stuff
as long as they let they respect it they
improved and love if you choose those
four philosophies it's impossible for
him to just to be a math teacher he
would eventually if he's constantly
improving he would end up becoming the
best math teacher or go to a university
or end up starting his own school
because that's the only thing that
happens if you focus on constantly
improving no matter what you choose to
do so that would be that's the
conversation I've had with these guys
for quite a while now if you want to
watch the full episode you're going to
click right here and if you want to ask
me a question one on one you want to do
a one-on-one face time with a group of
your friends whatever you want you need
to download manect right now click right
here and let's get talking
foreign